hello everyone my name is fabian and i
am one of the shops top of baby the
stars shine bright san francisco baby
the stars shine bright is a lolita
fashion company we sell a popular
fashion from japan called Lolita Lolita
is a very cute and frilly fashion based
on victorian and Rococo style clothing
so if you think of Alice in Wonderland
or Marie Antoinette's baby the stars
shine bright loves these bowls kind of
periods and old pattern that's just
super girly and frilly there's lots of
lace lots of cute patterns sometimes
there's gothic patterns and coffins and
crosses and skeletons it's a very
diverse pattern or fashion but the theme
is the same being girly and cute and
elegant and yourself so I personally got
into lolita only a few years ago I want
to say about four I really liked
victorian style and I was literally
fooling I think Victorian fashion and
actually baby the stars shine bright
pops up because that's one of their
biggest games is modeling a certain time
eras and I just immediately fell in love
I've bought my first dress I went to the
meetups I met all of the great girls and
boys in the community and I've been in
love ever since and I hope I never get
over it because it's so freely into
today on behalf of
the stars shine bright I want to thank
you so much for watching this video and
we hope to see you soon at our store in
San Francisco
you